so what's the plan today what are we
gonna cook all right we got two
different dishes okay uh what's first
the first one we're gonna make for you
is an American wagyu outside skirt steak
Street Taco uh and we used our very own
seasoning on this which is a salt and
pepper rub and Mexican chili okay so
it's got guajillo ancho activated
charcoal garlic cumin what is activated
charcoal what does that mean it's
coconut shells actually roasted roasted
coconut shells okay I feel like since
we're about to taste these we need to
bring in uh come over here
maybe that's going to eat actual food
lumet is like John Hein he's kind of a
baby can I can I tell you something that
happens like that yesterday I'm curious
as as people who cook for a living we
were trying to decide where to go and
they were going to go to In-N-Out Burger
which I'm all about I did it the night
before but then uh rassan goes this is
awesome sandwich shop right around the
corner to Richmond goes gross sandwiches
I can get a sandwich anywhere I get I
can make a sandwich at home well I just
said the cold bread meat I just buy that
at the store the point of going to a
restaurant is to have something like
cooked for you to save yourself time
yeah eventually go to um Dave and
Buster's and have a steak your first
night here in L.A yeah I had well listen
the food they're providing us I don't
know if you saw what was on the menu
today but it was like steamed squash and
cabbage salad all right my man let me
ask you a question
we have a per diem and then you make a
decent living so you chose to go to Dave
and Buster's to get a steak when there's
a gazillion great steak houses I'm the
reason they build Applebee's in Times
Square because when I go to a new city I
like to know what I'm getting before I
go in I don't like surprises because
like you experience a city through the
food right exactly so true exactly
Applebee's here or Dave and Buster's
here you've missed out on a major
cultural experience or a meal that's
terrible that I you could have spared
myself because David
I wasn't going anywhere tacos look like
they're about ready to go yeah phase
over there what's that you're drizzling
on it that's the correct yep Mexican
Crema just a little bit a little bit
thinner of a sour cream but it's a
really good
I'm not a Spice guy I'm not a taco guy
I'm really not trying to be a dick
wow we don't need tacos I never like
tacos I don't know
yeah tell me what exactly about time
let's talk this through for real and be
like adults what about tacos don't you
like I don't know Gary I have a
nine-year-old I can navigate this yeah
so if you don't try it you'll never know
but this so this is just steak with a
little bit of cheese uh cilantro chili
white onion white onion and the Cotija
is salty so it's almost like a finishing
cheese but it's very close to feta so
and and then I'm just gonna do this a
little bit I'm just gonna do a little
bit of maldon see this is finishing salt
that's it he loves it
make that one here
this giant salt crystal yeah okay so all
right let's give it a try let's do it
all right so we're gonna try these tacos
first dish of two we're gonna try it
yeah this is the first of a couple so
you're gonna have to eat like a grown
man today
there's just so much stuff on this like
one thing at a time it's like five
things all right we're gonna dig into
this real quick
that's a good taco
Gary describe the flavors
give me a bunch I'm getting an amazing
spice am I is there Jalapeno in here
yeah this is the red jalapeno so I got
one of those that's great
the meat you don't even have to chew I
mean you chew it but it's not like
you're fighting with it and um
the cheese is like the last thing to
taste now let's go to um juvenile food
expert Matt Walker what do you think
I mean I agree about the meat being soft
like for an older guy like Gary not
having to chew it as much I think that's
that's probably good for me it's um
I don't know it's just too much like
it's fine it's just not something
are you saying you can only handle one
flavor at a time that's what it is yeah
it's not that it's bad it's not this bad
it's just it's too much I'm starting to
feel like the Met not liking this Taco
could be a compliment